what's with the jeans so your artwork
you posted on me I posted okay I have a
vlog if you guys go to my youtube
channel it's just Tom Segura I've posted
three vlogs but in my latest vlog vlog
it's so fine allows us to call it you
know my latest post this video over
twelve years old
I know I I show you a piece of artwork
that I made I don't think you should
show people I got some interesting
feedback now see I'm serious like I
don't I know you've posted it on
Instagram right no I put it on YouTube
also yeah I wouldn't I take it down I
think people are gonna question your
sanity in your mental health why do you
say that it's so mentally ill like I saw
it and I was like you got to show this
to your shrink cuz I think something's
wrong something's wrong dude it's like
when we started dating and there were
red flags and I ignored them this is
another one of those what are you
talking about it's so crazy what you
drew you left this and that yeah I mean
what are you doing to her right now what
are you doing let me describe it to the
listeners okay describe it so is that is
that you know who is that there's just a
man
it's a horrible profile yeah of a person
with their tongue sticking out and then
there's two bales of hay one brown is
that what that is one pink the bushes
yeah and then a gun with the bullet
pointing to the guy's head and then
what's that up here that is the Sun that
black sign because dark times are upon
us I mean if you speak to an artist you
have to be willing to deal with okay the
explanation and that's not a gun firing
a bullet what is it shooting a fart why
didn't you say that well I don't have to
yeah but I'd rather know that now it
makes sense I mean before you think that
Dali and Picasso Monet go well here what
I was trying to do here I mean you know
I don't feel like explaining it so
artists this man how come is that a
mohawk that he has
no there's just regular here okay and
then how come he's got is that shit on
his neck no it's blood okay someone
stabbed him like that right before the
painting took place you left this in the
condo yeah did you sign it yeah oh my
god you think is it I'm gonna get in
trouble
no I think someone's gonna report you as
being what - mental health of the year
look can I read some of the comments
sure the Nate be 503 writes what the
fuck you're a regular Pablo Picasso
uh-huh
you are the king of painting is there
anything you can't do no almost as
remarkable as your many accents is this
painted with your pubes it's very nice
I'll appreciate any of those comments
guys what's your Instagram account so
people can come and see this monstrosity
it's Agora Tom because a 16 year old
British boy named Tom cigarette - Tom
cigarette I think it does kind of worry
me honestly when you showed it to me I
did kind of go like inside a little